with speculation swirling that Avengers
endgame will find Earth's Mightiest
Heroes traveling through time there's no
telling who they might encounter along
the way no character from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is off the table so
here's a look at some dead MCU
characters we might see in Avengers and
Game of all the characters in the rich
history of the MCU Brock rumlow probably
wouldn't be voted most likely to return
but the villain known as crossbones who
first appeared in Captain America the
Winter Soldier before dying in Captain
America Civil War seems to be making a
comeback Frank Grillo who plays
crossbones revealed on the podcast UFC
unfiltered that he is indeed returning
in a flashback in Avengers and game
usually Marvel keeps a tight lid on
spoilers but as Grillo explained I'm
allowed to say whatever I want because
I'm never doing another Marvel movie
another character fans expect to appear
in Avengers endgame is Captain America's
one true love Peggy Carter she's made a
number of high-profile appearances in
the MCU from the 1940s through the
present before passing away in Captain
America Civil War but in 2017 star
Hayley Atwell stoked rumors of a return
to the MCU by posting a photo on social
media that seemed to be from the set of
Avengers end game considering Marvel
made a point of including her in the
first endgame trailer it seems possible
the fan theory that cap and Peggy will
be reunited may actually come true one
of the most talked about moments in
Avengers infinity war is the scene where
Thanos communes with the spirit of
Gamora the adopted daughter he murdered
earlier in the film it was later
revealed that as fans had guessed the
reunion took place inside the soul stone
which in the comics is known for storing
the spirits of dead heroes until they
are ready to be resurrected so it seems
like there's a pretty fair vet that
before endgame is over Gamora will be
reborn and considering the circumstances
surrounding her death this is one
father-daughter dance we don't want to
miss vision has already been brought
back from the dead once through the
power of the time stone so we know it's
possible of course he was then
immediately killed again but as an
artificial life-form even if the
Infinity stones aren't involved it's
theoretically possible he could be
rebuilt by Sheree or Tony Stark one way
or another his love story with Skaar
which deserves a happier ending like
crossbones Arnim Zola isn't an obvious
choice for resurrection but we know
Marvel's filmmakers have been trying to
get him back into the picture as he
almost appeared in ant-man's eighties
flashback and there are two easy ways to
get him in the picture firstly in Winter
Soldier we saw that he had achieved
digital immortality by uploading his
consciousness to an old computer system
while that was destroyed it would be
super easy to have backups more
interesting though is the fact that Zola
was alive and active as a Hydra mole
inside shield for several decades after
world war two that would make him a
perfect villain to interact with the
Avengers if they go back in time and
would also make it easy for his story to
intersect with a Peggy Carter appearance
connect those dots Marvel another
character active in the past is Black
Panthers father King to Chaka
now that the Avengers know about
wakanda's technological superiority that
could very well contact to Chaka for
help in the past but we can also see
Black Panther himself after all we know
that the Monarchs of Wakanda live on in
a spiritual after world ready to guide
those who come after whether it's Sheree
or mbaku
whoever takes the throne of Wakanda
after two challahs death may very well
visit him in the afterlife even in death
the black panther protects his people
the Asgardian god of mischief has
already spent so much of his time in the
MCU dying and coming back with all the
times this greasy little opossum has
faked out the audience it's no surprise
that Thanos felt the need to declare
that Loki would get no resurrections
this time it also means we're not
entirely ready to believe him and he's
not the only dead Asgardian who could
make a comeback every single person in
Thor's life is either dead or missing
having Odin or Heimdall or the long-lost
sift return would finally give the god
of thunder a little hope among all this
loss speaking of lost families the
members of the guardians of the galaxy
have been struggling with their ghosts
from day one everybody's got dead people
it's no excuse to get everybody else
dead along the way with most of the
guardians now dead themselves the stage
could be set for some more reunions in
the afterlife of the soul stone
Drax's wife and child Peter's mom
gamora's real parents they're all
possibilities in endgame
perhaps the most important lost family
in the MCU though are Tony Stark's
parents Howard and Maria
Tony's fraught relationship with Howard
was the focal point of Iron Man 2 and
the circumstances behind their death
drove the plot of Captain America Civil
War considering many people expect
endgame to be the final chapter in
Tony's story it would be fanatically
appropriate and emotionally satisfying
if Tony and his parents were reunited
perhaps even more important though is
the fact that Howard Stark is a
co-founder of shield and thus the
spiritual father of the Avengers
themselves considering the credits for
end games strongly hint that some part
of the film takes place in the 1970s
it's very possible we may see Howard and
Tony Stark team up to defeat Thanos
together what is and always will be my
greatest creation
is you it got a little tough to keep
track of everything that was happening
in age of Ultron remember Quicksilver
scarlet witch's brother Pietro Maximoff
he ran really fast and died protecting
Clint Barton from a hail of bullets as
sokovia fell from the sky it's easy to
forget those since even his sister
hasn't even mentioned him in the years
since his death but that doesn't mean
he's been completely forgotten with
Disney's acquisition of Fox opening the
door to the addition of the x-men and
their version of Quicksilver to the MCU
bringing back Marvel's version of
Quicksilver might be an interesting and
unexpected way to begin that transition
into the next phase of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe no matter what Marvel
tells us we all know that not all of
those deaths in the climax of infinity
war were permanent heck Marvel has
already announced films featuring a
number of dead characters including
spider-man far from home
which is slated to open less than three
months after endgame it's not a question
of if we'll see the return of spider-man
Black Panther and Doctor Strange it's
just a matter of how we can't wait to
find out
[Music]